The David Pakman show sub reddit has surged
beyond 10,000 to almost 11,000 of our viewers
and listeners, this is where a lot of really
great political discussion is taking place.
You can find it at David pakman.com/reddit
a couple of interesting posts that I want
to call your attention to that I spotted this
morning from the David Pakman show, sub reddit,
including one titled Tim Pool Calls Out.
David Pakman.
Listen, I watched the video Tim pool mentioned
in the mildest way that he disagrees with
me about the degree to which some issues are
problems.
Okay.
Uh, I told him during our conversation on
my youtube channel that I believe that the
identity politics, SJW speech suppressing
left is a problem to the extent that it exists,
but it's a relatively small problem.
And in a video he recently did, he said he
disagrees with me about the extent to which
that's a problem.
This is not a call out.
This doesn't mean I agree with Tim about anything
in particular, but this is a very, very okay
thing for him to do.
I'm not offended, I'm not triggered.
He's not calling me out.
He's just saying we have a difference of opinion
and that's it.
So please don't try to start drama.
Second thread I want to mention to you.
Um, there is someone who is mad at me that
I recently said, hey, if you go to some of
these upcoming Dave Rubin events, ask questions
related to the David Pakman show and it's
likely to get on the show and someone posted,
make sure you make it all about me.
They are translating.
What I said is make sure you make a Dave Rubin
event all about me.
Listen up for this show, Dave Rubin.
Taking questions in public is not super interesting
unless it relates to the show.
Like if you go and ask Dave Rubin about income
taxes, it's not super interesting for the
David Pakman show.
Who cares what Dave Ruben has to say about
income taxes when someone asks him that in
the crowd?
If you're interested in me talking about funny
or interesting questions that you ask Dave
Rubin, what would be relevant to this show
would be if it's about the David Pakman show,
if it's about what lies did.
David, did David Pakman say about you?
Uh, are you willing to talk to David Packman?
I don't think that this is really a big deal
and trying to make it once again dramatic
as if there is some kind of like narcissism
or arrogance in me saying if you ask Dave
Ruben about me, I'll play it on the show asking
Dave Ruben about, you know, uh, uh, Ben Shapiro
is not going to be very interesting to our
audience.
So that is that.
Please join the discussion@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit uh, almost 11,000 of you are
regularly participating in moderated.
We have multiple moderators on the subreddit,
respectful political discussion and uh, I
encourage you to join.
Pat and I are both regulars on the David Pakman
show, sub reddit.